hey yes what's up this is andrew for
10senses.com so in this video i would
like to talk about what happened
yesterday guys on amc and gamestop and
most importantly i would like to
explain what is happening to me with
dwac and phun
trump's companies that basically sucked
all the volume
out of amc indian stuff so let's get
into
[Music]
it right guys so this is a very
important day it's the first time i see
that basically we have uh
two stocks
so dwac and phun you can see guys the
crazy moves they made so dwac went up
first
300 percent and then 100 percent
and uh ph u n went up
fifty percent and then it was up one
thousand percent uh during the day and
closed the day up only 500
what is very important here is to look
at the volume so first you can see that
the dwac volume was huge on thursday
so 500 million shares exchanged at
roughly okay let's say 10
so it's like 5 billion
and then 5 billion again in terms of
volume of dollars
but here we can see that the volume
dropped okay between thursday and friday
and where did it go it went to p-h-u-n
guys so here the voting was not that big
on thursday
okay 100 million shares so roughly at
one so roughly 100 million dollars and
here
we have 600 million shares exchanged
roughly at 10.
okay so it's like 6 billion us dollars
and dwac sorry it was yesterday 100
million shares
times 100 so 10 billion us dollars okay
so 10 plus five roughly 15 billion us
dollars i remind you guys that the first
day gamestop squeezed 20 billion us
dollars were exchanged so this is the
same amount roughly 15 20 it's the same
so it's very easy to understand what
happened here i will post tomorrow a
video about amc and the day after about
being stopped where i mostly talk about
amc and gamestop technicals and once
again i don't want to pump dwac and phun
because i know that this is the reason
why we made those losses on gamestop and
amc but i want to analyze as honestly as
i can
what might happen on those two because
if the bullish momentum keeps happening
on those two aims in gamestop are in
danger
so this is the point of this video so
let's analyze a bit uh let's check
quickly what happened okay so you have
here an article that is basically saying
the same thing i do so i'm saying that
since yesterday i mean everybody i think
understood what is happening here i
didn't get my information from here but
it's interesting to see that this
article is saying the same thing so
basically much like blah blah blah
mc and gamestop are wondering where all
of the supporters are now that the magya
crowd has knocked down the door both of
the biggest names in meme stacks closed
down on friday blah blah blah trump dwac
up 100 up 500 sword respectively after
wednesday's announcement that trump will
take his new trump media and technology
group public via uh space deal with
digital worlds all right so we have a
news we don't have any options on those
two i have checked that already so we
have a news we can once again do this
analysis so strong volume and dwac then
lower volume you can see here 500
million shares then only 100 and all the
volume went in phum okay
so phum is uh now the stock to analyze i
mean it's still more here 10 billion
still more than patron only six
but we can see the dynamics it's
shifting from dwac to phum now if we
have a look at based on some news about
shrimp companies so the question we're
having is is it going to last and what
can we check here so we don't have much
we can check to be honest there is one
thing we can do there is one thing is
that now we
kind of
see that the one that is really hot is
ph2 and this one guys is not a new stock
is a stock with a lot of back holders
right
so this is the only good news i see once
again good news it's not i wish trump a
lot of success i mean i have nothing
against the guy it's just that it's
sucking out the flows from amc and stuff
which i believe
are very important for a lot of people
that are involved in this i'm talking
about those two for a long time i will
keep you know talking about incendium
stuff and everything that is going
against the bullish price action of
those two is for me not good so i
consider a bit those two stocks like the
enemies of amc and gamestop and there's
nothing else we can say now i know
that's probably a bit the same investors
so maybe some of you guys are in those
two i mean you're not my enemy but you
know come back to amc and gamestop yes
this is the real place this is where big
things might happen all right and here
there are a lot of back holders guys on
phrase so
maybe they're gonna get scared and
they're just gonna escape you know
because some of them bought much higher
we're turning at 10 the stock was
trading at 200 guys even 500 all right a
few years ago
so
when i see that it gives me hope that a
move down might happen i mean if it was
newer than high the bullish momentum
would be very strong i mean here is
still very strong i'm not saying it's
going to drop on monday i'm just trying
to understand what kind of actors we
have in this market who might do what
and here there are some guys that both
long time ago that might just take
profits so it's going to be very
interesting to see if we have higher
highs here this is really not good for
amazing game stuff that i will once
again make a big analysis tomorrow and
the day after and here the only bad
things i found is that you know some
people already make fun of this you know
trump's venture is predicated on a
social media app called traff which has
already been hacked to show close-up
videos of pigs pooping on themselves on
an account link to trump himself alright
so trump has uh you know some enemies as
well that try to make fun of him that
try to put down his company's reputation
so
you know there are some clouds in the
sky it's not uh a green scale we have
those back holders in phu end where the
volume is clearly going right now
uh and we have those buttons i mean
those jokes that i made about trump i
mean at least his companies and we don't
have options so i cannot check if the
move would last i mean on gamestop and
name sienna we have options and in gen
22 gen 23 people really believe in it
and i don't think that um
dwac and patreon can suddenly become the
new mcn gamestop i really don't believe
that uh once again i will not
be from those who pump it because i know
that it's not benefiting um amc and
gamestop
but i'm just i just want to share what i
see the analysis i make about those
let's try to find some resistance
on phun so we have one here i mean ta is
not very helpful here let's be honest
guys because it's just too crazy i was
basically asked by the way on my discord
to make some analysis here and i was
saying oh we have a big resistance at
240. but guys i mean you know we just
fly over the resistance so right now we
have a resistance
at 11. it has not been respected
yesterday so i i mean
this kind of move they're not respecting
ta it's too brutal so let's see what is
happening but what is for sure is that
there are bike holders in this uh trade
and
they would probably try to take some
profits so many things will happen in
coming days we're going to follow this
closely once again guys uh there is
negative correlation between the new uh
meme the dwac and phum and amc gamestop
which are the real players guys so keep
that in mind come back home guys
everything is gonna i think happen as it
should if nothing is disturbing the
situation and once again all of this
comes back i mean it comes from the
reason that there is a lot of money in
the economy because of the crisis of
everything that you know just generated
these big inflows of money in the
economy and this money is going uh to
aim cindy stop
so as long as there is no other stocks
that can take this those two will
eventually squeeze this is what i
believe so that's it for me i hope you
guys enjoyed this video and if you did
please don't forget to click on the sub
like and bell button so you're gonna be
the first to know when i upload anything
new and stay close to show see you guys